For decades, scientists have been digging
up dirt about the surface of Mars. But
what do we know about its atmosphere? Now, scientists have probed the upper
atmosphere of the Red Planet to discover
what it's made of and why Mars lost most
of it to space. The Martian atmosphere is
rife with carbon dioxide with smaller
amounts of nitrogen and argon. Studying
Mars's atmosphere could reveal the
history of its climate and help answer a
vexing question: Was Mars ever habitable?
It could also provide clues for
understanding our own planet. Since 2014,
NASA's MAVEN spacecraft has been
studying Mars's atmosphere,
orbiting the planet a whopping eight
thousand-plus times in four years.
Previous probes have discovered all
sorts of things about Mars's lower
atmosphere. The Mars Reconnaissance
Orbiter gauged the temperature, water and
ozone concentrations and the ExoMars
trace gas orbiter scoped out gases like
methane, which could be evidence for
biological and geological activity. But a
crucial piece of the puzzle was missing
data from a region of the upper
atmosphere known as the thermosphere. The latest study used MAVEN to measure wind
patterns roughly 140 to 240 kilometers
above the planet's surface. Over one and
a half Mars years, roughly 687 Earth days,
the spacecraft repeatedly dipped from
space down into Mars's thermosphere. As if using a butterfly net it captured
molecules and analyzed them with mass
spectrometry, allowing scientists to
measure the wind velocities.
The data showed that wind in Mars's
thermosphere circulates in simpler ways
than on Earth in patterns that persist
over multiple seasons. Giant atmospheric
waves are generated by large variations
in the height of Mars's surface far
below. These results bring scientists a
few steps closer to solving the riddle
of Mars's upper atmosphere, shedding
light on its makeup and contributing to
big objectives like the search for
habitable planets and the delivery of a
complete picture of Earth's climate. Just
maybe, that could remind people back on
earth why we look to the sky for answers.